Okay, this is for white people,
so if you're not white, just keep scrolling.
So if you've got these tiny lips like me
and you've been considering filler,
cancel them now. You have to see what medikube just dropped this week.
I'm nervous to even use this stick cause it has volufiline and pdrn.
You don't know about volufiline?
Just look it up. People are literally building back their collagen loss,
like under their eyes, naturally building out their lips
thicker than Kylie
so you get mega hydration and plumping that actually builds thicker
juicier lips. For real.
And one lady even put it on one of her fingers to rub it under her eye
and that finger had bumped out by the end of the video.
Like I'm 38 and I've been too afraid to try this stuff
cause I wanna be very tactical where I put it.
It pairs super well with medicubes new collagen and PDR
and eye patches. You can find this by itself
or bundle them for a crazy discount at the link right here.
Cause medicubes newest products always have the craziest savings.
But they sell out so fast
so hopefully you can still see the link and kiss your filler goodbye.